okay today I'm going to talk to you
about covalent bonding but a particular
skill about covalent bonding of how to
draw dot and cross diagrams so the
couple of little skills were a couple of
bits of information we need to know
before we get started and that is
covalent bonding occurs between
nonmetals and also that covalent bonding
involves sharing electrons
so now we have those key fundamental
bits of information let's get started
now what we're going to do is we're
going to draw a diagram to show how
hydrogen
bonds with chlorine
so what I'm doing right now is I'm
drawing the outer shell of hydrogen and
outer shell of chlorine now hydrogen has
only got one electron in total so this
is its first shell remember any atom
needs two electrons to fill up the first
shell
chlorine this isn't its first shell this
is its outer shell so it has seven
electrons in that outer shell it's in
group seven of the periodic table now
hydrogen needs one more electron to have
a full outer shell because this is the
first shell and needs to to be full
chlorine also needs just one more
electron because it needs eight
electrons in total to have a full outer
shell so we could see they both need one
more electron to be stable so
they bond together and this is how we
draw it now what I'm going to do to
begin with here is I'm just drawing the
electrons that are not involved in the
covalent bond on the chlorine so there's
the ones that aren't and
here's my hydrogen notice how I've drawn
these two shells overlapping now in the
middle I'm drawing the pair of electrons
which are being shared one from the
hydrogen and one from the chlorine if we
now count the electrons in each out of
shells so for chlorine one two three
four five six seven eight so it's got a
full outer shell and for hydrogen one
two it's got a full outer shell
please notice how I didn't draw the
electron over here and I've drawn them
in the middle because it shows that
these electrons are being shared
also notice the reason why it's called a
dot and cross diagram is we always draw
the electrons on one atom with dots or
sorry with dots and the other with a
cross this is just a show which Aten
they originally belong to it they
they're actually both still exactly the
same they're both just electrons so the
whole point of dr. Krauss is just
showing which ultimate belong to
originally
now the other example I'm going to do is
I'm going to show you how to do an
oxygen molecule
so here we have oxygen
which has
six electrons in the outer shell I
didn't draw that very well so I'm going
to draw this one over there
there we go so we could see that this
oxygen atom needs two more electrons to
have a full outer shell and this oxygen
atom also needs two more electrons to
have a full outer shell so they are
going to share this time this one is
going to share two with this oxygen and
this oxygen is going to share two with
this oxygen so let's draw them so again
I've drawn these two atoms overlap in
just writing on over oxygen in the
middle so we could see this time there's
two of those electrons are going to be
shared from this one and two are going
to be shared from this one
so there's just the other electrons that
make it up
so now if we count the electrons we can
see that this oxygen atom here now has 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so it's stable and this
oxygen atom here has 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so
this is stable so just the recap the
important things are we know that this
only occurs between nonmetals and
covalent bonding is sharing of electrons
we think how many more electrons does
your attorney to have a full outer shell
we draw the the electrons from one atom
with across the other with a dot to show
that they're from different atoms and we
draw these electrons in the middle to
show that being shared if we get all of
that stuff right we should be okay thank
you